China’s spies have gotten a lot of unwanted attention recently
thanks in part to political and trade tensions between China and the U.S.
Many of those spies work for the country's main intelligence agency,
the Ministry of State Security - or MSS.
In December 2018, one of China’s top tech executives was arrested in Canada on a U.S. extradition request -
soon after, MSS agents abruptly detained two Canadians in China.
Then days later the U.S. publicly named two of MSS’s alleged assets
as part of a sweeping U.S. indictment involving hacking on a global scale.
The series of events has people asking - what exactly is the MSS?
This is your Bloomberg QuickTake on China’s elusive spies.
Compared with the U.S., the MSS is something of a mash-up.
It conducts intelligence operations abroad - like the CIA;
counterespionage at home - like the FBI; and cyber-snooping - like the NSA.
What is clear, is that the MSS is key to Chinese President Xi Jinping’s efforts to tighten control over security.
Its head - Chen Wenqing - is an ex-police chief who helped direct Xi's nationwide anti-graft campaign.
In 2015, the National Security Law extended the MSS's power
to outer space and the deep sea as well as the internet.
The MSS operates secret detention facilities within China
and is known for its harsh treatment of dissidents.
For example, the blind civil-rights lawyer Chen Guangcheng was under house arrest for 19 months
before he fled to the U.S. Embassy in Beijing in 2012 and eventually moved to New York.
Media reports have noted some key MSS victories including the possibility that
they monitored president Donald Trump’s calls made on unsecured cellular devices.
There was also a report that the MSS had dismantled CIA operations in China over several years -
killing a dozen or more of the agency's sources -
reportedly in one of the worst U.S. intelligence breaches in decades.